Benjamin Franklin apparently said tell
me and I forget teach me and I remember
involve me and I learn but what do we
really know about effective learning
hundreds of years later many respected
economists and educators from the
world's leading universities researched
this topic they discovered that many
things don't matter such as classroom
size new technology or fancy uniforms
their evidence suggests that the secret
to thriving students is amazing teachers
here's what they have learned first we
have to acknowledge that teaching is a
highly complex skill it involves a deep
understanding of the subject matter and
the ability to explain complex issues in
simple ways but it also requires an
understanding of psychology pedagogy as
well as a wide range of management
skills in order to get the students
first quiet and then excited robco
professor at Durham University reported
that many widely used methods don't work
for example grouping students by ability
giving unearned praise or the idea that
students can discover complex concepts
by themselves instead master instructors
have high expectations and maximize the
lesson time but most importantly they
combine high quality instruction with
pedagogical content knowledge they don't
teach a subject they teach their
students how to learn it for themselves
in order to get it right we have to
treat and train teachers like brain
surgeons
after all they operate on human brains
like aspiring doctors they are best
trained in the field where they receive
professional feedback when they make
mistakes effective schools of Education
therefore train teaching like a craft
rather than an abstract science at
Sposato a Graduate School of Education
known for creating effective teachers
students spend a lot of their time
tutoring or assisting for
teachers who were already in the
classroom need regular professional
feedback on the job
avast study by Roland fryer from Harvard
found that teachers who received precise
instructions together with specific
regular feedback from a lead teacher
will improve the most other good ideas
to improve teachers are to ask the
students for feedback or to record
lessons on video and let the teachers
watch themselves
Doug Lomov founder of uncommon schools
and author of teach like a champion
identified many methods that great
teachers use they greet each student at
the door so students feel welcomed and
acknowledged of their existence
later they use a strong voice and don't
stop talking until they have everyone's
attention plus they teach from mastery
learning to ensure students get it a
hundred percent right before they
proceed but maybe most importantly great
teachers first get their students
excited and then keep their attention
through storytelling and engaging
activities that spark their imaginations
a paper published by Stanford in 2009
showed that leadership makes a big
difference to at low-performing schools
principals hardly ever show up in the
classrooms but instead spend most of
their time on administration documents
or finance schools with better students
have principals that get out of their
office and spend a lot of time in the
classrooms supervising and developing
the teachers together they can make a
big difference in their students life
[Music]
economist Raj Chetty and his team
analyzed the data of 2.5 million US
students and 18 million test results he
thinks that instructors who are good at
teaching to the test have a big impact
on average having such a teacher for
just one year raises the students test
scores and cumulative lifetime income by
14,500 in 2011 dollars on early
childhood education
he has another
great kindergarten teachers help to
develop social skills discipline and
character their impact does not improve
test scores during the school years but
surprisingly re-emerges years later when
their former students apply those skills
to advance in their careers and find
meaningful and well-paying jobs
Eric Hanushek professor at Stanford
University computed how much good
teachers really matter he found out that
top teachers get students to learn 50%
more each year than an average
instructor poorly trained ones just half
of the average that means that 10 years
at school can either result in 15 years
of actual learning or just a mere 5
years this is a massive difference that
mainly hurts children from low-income
families who can't afford extra classes
or changing to a better school American
novelist Gayle Godwin once wrote good
teaching is one fourth preparation and
three-fourths pure theater to see great
actors in action watch Michael Sandel
from Harvard teach law Robert Sapolsky
from Stanford teach behavioral biology
Walter Mischel from MIT teach physics on
mr. Hester managing a classroom of
teenagers links are in the description
below and other great instructors in our
channel playlists now please share your
favorite teachers in the comments below
[Music]
[Music]